[Music]
they advise the congregation to wear
masks and maintain social distance
you can judge for yourself how many
actually do
these so-called revival meetings on the
beaches of southern california
are taking place in violation of public
health orders
and at a time when coronavirus cases and
deaths
are surging here
the police were there but took no action
they admit there's only
so much they can do at an event with
hundreds taking part
he is the king of kings
they've been forced to move here to
newport beach as the standoff with
authorities has grown
the previous week the local council
along the coast have put up road signs
saying the event was cancelled
you can't cancel jesus said the
organizer
they drowned out police warnings and
continue with the service
it is they say their right to do this
[Applause]
the authorities are saying don't do it
should you not be abiding by what
they're saying
yeah i think ultimately and i guess it's
kind of like where you stand
politically but for us we believe that
like as an american citizen
the the authority is the people so the
government
i mean they're meant to protect the will
of the people so when
there is that tension of government
power i think people start to wonder
like is this
america still it's worth pointing out
that this is
orange county a place where you can look
around and almost believe the corona
virus has never happened
masks are few and far between even in
the shops
and people here support that right to
congregate
my opinion has always been we're in the
open air and being at the beach
i mean you've always got a breeze going
and to me i think that that's the best
way to
be outside they want us all to be
outside and i think you're
you know god is everywhere back at the
revival they head for the water
baptisms in the pacific ocean are why
many people come
and few believe there's a risk in any of
this i think that people should be free
to choose whether they want to wear
masks
or not and personally i feel healthier
when i don't wear a mask
i have no fear there's no i think the
news is lying
i'll just say it like that about the
virus not about the virus about the
numbers and the stats and everyone i
know i know a lot of people that have
gotten coveted but um they're all fine
they're all better
and i know a ton of people that are
walking around here that aren't
have never been you know have not got
sick at all
if you go out you're not feeling well
that's irresponsible
to make it a responsible choice i think
people are doing that here tonight i
would hope so
you know you can't you can't control it
one way or the other you really can't
god gave me the word for coved instead
of covet 19 is christ overcoming victory
in disease psalm
19. you know what that's what i believe
covet yes if you have a comorbidity if
you have
issues then stay home but you know what
there's there was thousands of
protesters
they didn't have mask on so we're
protesting for jesus
they say there's no way they can stop
this now because they believe they
answer a higher authority
even if that's put them in direct
conflict with the rules of
a more earthly one greg milam sky news
orange county in california